talent all right welcome to another
spontaneous entrepreneur QA got a bunch
of questions for those you watching live
you can ask the question too and that's
it here we go let's get to it first
question is it is it like cheeky coming
in now it's non seems okay but what's
the first class little shaky first
questions over here Angelo I commit with
my dreams but in this point of my life
with a day job I need some cash business
first fro from after doing my dream
project my dreams involved a radical
change to change the world and probably
have not no income at all what do you
think about this thank you for the
response what do you think oh man I feel
we've covered this a few times but what
is the first time we've done it you know
it's been wide I'm gonna win so start
one listen so so whatever your dream is
almost certainly there's a small version
of it like a doable performable
money-making version of it that can be
done if your if your vision is to create
like a giant new city maybe your first
step is designing on paper and shopping
that idea around to investors or maybe
it's amassing a team building up people
collaborators who get the vision maybe
you could coach people on cities and
charge for that like there's there's
almost always a small version a seed
version of your dream that you can make
money at while moving forward yeah and
I'm just looking at the question again
like my dream project involves radical
change which would have no income at all
and I you know just challenged I like
why why can't you have income why can't
you provide and singing value to people
and making income at the same time and
then and then to j reyez this point here
finest holla to get started now like
don't take some cash business part-time
thing that doesn't support your future
ambition find a way to break it down and
get going help empire builders i love it
any bounces i like the best
advanced the bounce I always also
secured the next question what word like
it was it was a good quick I'm
distracted okay uh Syed hello Evan and
how are you I'm fine how are you I'm
great but there you go thank you for the
History Channel videos I have a question
what is the best way to create your own
website uh like an Instagram or any
other business work ideas to create your
own website what do you think ah it
seems a little vague there's tons of
ways to create a website but i would i
would go with Wix or wordpress com or
there's a bunch of free free websites
like you know you can experiment with i
can't i do want to Instagram level
website uh you know i mean again start
small put your idea together shop it
around see if someone wants to come on
board collaborate hopefully you can
offer some value to them in return or
they can build their portfolio or you
could get an intern or try someone an
upward or fiber like I you know I don't
know yeah i like i love the practical
hands-on I would if I was starting over
I would look at WordPress for sure and
I'm even though I'm not starting over
i'm still looking at WordPress anyways
so that's that's the easiest one to go
to ruben abuzz against it oh really yeah
well whatever shine about diner is like
a little chat about that offline um why
did he put any advice again see the
smart dude all right wow it's from
information I know right now I would go
with WordPress yeah me too um but I you
know I would also be starting with
what's what's the why like why are you
doing this what's the impacts are with
your values um because you know as
junior I said there's a ton of websites
out there what's going to make your
stand out it's your story your story
your why your beliefs or values that's
going to make you stand out from
everybody else in whatever field that
you're going for it and it's I mean that
can apply to any any marketing that
you're doing should always start with
the why I should I start with your story
should always start with your passion I
think too many entrepreneurs don't tell
their store and they have a boring
marketing website boring business card
Laureen you know brochures born
videos and you're trying to be corporate
where people don't like buying from
companies they want to buy from you like
you if you look the same as a company
i'm going to go with the company because
there they have a better track record
right there more established exactly so
being able to make it personal show how
much this means to you is what's going
to make me go with you so make sure you
tell your story all the market that you
do nice size sahib sobs I epipe announce
a site site I'm an entrepreneur from
Jordan in the Middle East I'm starting
my own business which is your attack
consuming I'm a mechanical engineer and
designer are used to design aircraft so
many other things I have lots of product
designs in many fields currently I'm
constrained in my new business I don't
have any free time for anything else or
neglected most of his ideas but I know
they have great potential I don't know
how to sell them so what do you think
you know he's got a full-time job he's
got all these ideas he doesn't have time
to do them well you can either look at
priorities like what's important to you
and if your priorities are this idea is
most important to me than you you know
when your party priorities are strong
like that you find a way like I do it at
lunch at work or I do it in the bathroom
at work or you know the peak there's
tons of stories of people who had a
dream and they got started up in this
like compressed little time period in
these they did whatever they could to
squeeze it and Gary Gary Vaynerchuk
talks about this a lot but the second
thing is a what Evan often says is made
your time better uh chunk it automated
delegated leverage it use other people's
time i'm like i don't i'm not sure your
situation if it's a priorities issue or
if it's a time management thing but you
can free up your time you can aah yeah
there's a there's an expression the
figures are the big rocks have to go in
first nice right there's a kind of
age-old time management principle where
they store you have a you have a bowl
and then you have big rocks little rocks
and sand if you put the sand in first
and the little
box in next and there's no space for the
big rocks where you want to put the big
rocks in first and then the little rocks
and the same fills up the space so the
point is if you're not purposely putting
your big rocks in first the things that
are most important to you first then the
sand and all the little things in life
will find ways to monopolize your time
and so yes you have a full-time job I
mean welcome to the world of
entrepreneurship when you're starting
out you know you don't just start and
say oh I have all this time and all this
money to just sit around and do whatever
I want right like it's a struggle you
got to build it up so you got a schedule
in time for your idea half an hour day
an hour a day every single day no
excuses put it on your calendar if it's
ten thirty two eleven o'clock at night
every night that's when you're working
way in your dream like you can't expect
great things that happen if you're not
putting in the time to make it happen
even if it's a little bit every day to
allow that momentum to grow you're just
gonna you're gonna you're going to die
with your song still in you right you're
going to die with all these ideas and
just wish that you know when i was
younger i wish that i took the time to
what'd you go and do it right find the
time you have the time we all put it in
your calendar right so a little harsh
love but you know i mean you can do it i
believe in you there you go there's the
there's the belief i'm going to believe
okay I Rouge hey recent started watching
videos I think they're amazing and very
helpful thank you Rouge uh I have an
issue with my business I'm 16-9 nursey
entrepreneur and I've been asked her
since I was nine because of my age is
something is difficult to get people
take me seriously my age is cause more
than a few drawbacks in my business I've
been denied access the business networks
business events how do I take advantage
of my young age in the business world
dude you have an amazing video of this I
wish I could remember which one it is
you're like you're like if you want
people to take you seriously you're
talking to another young entrepreneur
command command authority command
respect right other people will only
take you as seriously as you take
yourself if you carry yourself like if
you just put your age aside and ignore
it and you like walk in with your
whatever product ideas beliefs
and and and you stand firm on those and
you're ready to walk away and stand up
for him and do whatever it takes them
people will feel that people resonate it
doesn't matter how old you are people
can feel someone who's got a great
product or if you're ready to help
someone you know your stuff can help
them then you you put it all out there
and you be take yourself seriously if
they're not open to it they're not the
right customer for you and you move on
like any entrepreneur would Zeno's write
in comments not the age thing again now
Zeno comment on my youtube channel a
little while ago saying that he feels
he's too old that he's 25 25 I once a
2596 feels like he's too old so the same
thing applies man too young to old what
I liked about this but I liked about the
end of the question was how do I take
advantage of my young agent of his nice
that's actually good not just saying
like I should come so he's not able to
get into networking events all this
stuff because he's too young but how can
I take advantage so a young age start a
youth network yeah and play it up like
turn that turn that perceived weakness
into a strength where there's a lot of
companies that you know a lot of the
deals that I get are still because I'm
young now I'm not like massively young
what I'm 35 and I'm selling the people
who are way older than me because they
don't understand social media and how to
build a network online and they see me
as somebody who has done it and gets it
and so I play that up at the end of the
day it's really about the value like
having confidence that you can provide
value to these guys and I struggled with
that a lot when I was younger that why
would Microsoft want to talk to me like
what value cannot provide Microsoft but
it just came from realizing after
talking to them like I can actually
really help these guys they need some
serious help and just having confidence
in your abilities i mean when i was
starting i'm told to store a couple
times so just super quick but in my
software company i was 19 and selling
the guys three times my age and I was
too afraid to get on the phone and talk
with people and meet with them
face-to-face forget it because i figured
they wouldn't want to buy for me but
when i when i found out that they didn't
care how old i was just at how much of
value i could provide that that's what
they at the end of the day cared about
so if i'm a young entrepreneur I'm 16
you know a lot of the business
networking events and business events
suck man like I don't go to any business
events unless I'm speaking on a
conference I don't go to any of these
things so don't feel like that's holding
you back just create your own style get
online network with people through
YouTube and Facebook just like your
writing to me here uh seriously like
massively overrated I wouldn't I
wouldn't let I don't want you to think
that that that's holding you back from
achieving success hmm seriously i'd
totally agree i've been to a few and ya
know there was it there was a survey i
was looking out for a friend that forty
percent of people would rather go to
their dentist then go to watch another
presentation with PowerPoint slides yeah
I'm one of them it's boring man it's
boring tries me nuts solution okay Abby
nav hi Evan sir sure this is abhinav i
watch many of your believe videos loving
them love to design things differently
like my idol steve jobs i want to my own
interior designing company tedious what
can i do to start such a business so
somebody who wants to start an interior
design company what wisdom you have to
share Oh always simple provide value
help have you help people design
interiors can you help someone now
design interiors and when you do it can
you be rewarded for it like if you over
deliver right if you blow someone's mind
with interior design i I don't I had a
place and I I had a friend or someone
helped design the interior and they went
the extra mile and did a whole ton of
stuff I feel bad and guilty if I didn't
reward them somehow you know like
whether it's like tickets to a movie or
whatever but I wouldn't feel like paying
them you know I would feel like
reciprocating so I feel like unless
you're able to give some kind of design
experience design advice design coaching
design portfolio design ideas unless you
can do that and over-deliver and get
someone to feel positively towards you
and reward you for it then you got some
work to do yeah I you know my thoughts
on
any new business your your value comes
from from how much while the value comes
in value you know how much money going
to make comes from the value like your
success will come from how much you
value can provide so do you have the
chops to be able to provide value to
people you know that's why I need an
interior designer right now at TDS the
salsa business right here's your custom
little I over give me something man give
me some idea show your show your value
right and if you don't have the skills
yet then start by working for a company
that you look up to that's like 10
people or less we can learn from the CEO
founder get us closer than most
vulnerable and then start your business
you start on the side so our evening
certain weekends set up on the side just
to get you going I think a lot of people
start a business without having enough
experience a background in it and then
they flop because they can't provide the
value and also they run out of money you
know if you go full time and you don't
have enough cash its sustain yourself
end up going back and begging for your
old job so those two things work for
someone who you can learn from and if
you already have the skills then make
sure you demonstrating the value
demonstrate demonstrate the value like
if I saw some I'm looking for it was a
great example I'm looking for an awesome
dance studio interior design I can't
find one I can't find one like you look
online they've done his own show I went
to the design show in my city but I've
been looking online there's nothing
right if I saw you at this amazing day
in studio design poster I'd be like
calling this guy up said hey listen I
need help to design my dance studio
right and it and right there a sale is
made and so it's putting that value out
there to demonstrate that you have
skills that people could use we've a
call in Nice a calling good stuff
industries welcome good stuff good stuff
industries is connecting all right well
I'm excited anticipate in good stuff
it's good stuff industries I'm sure good
stuff was running and he read it now
okay we got it while we wait for the
connection there oh there he is what's
up good good stuff hey let's go yeah
your internets
it's kind of fuzzy man i'm not sure if
good stuff internet is good internet is
not so good news on sub sorry that's hey
there we go there we go audio only
what's up hey can you guys see it can
you hear me we hear you you hey how you
doing Evan Carmichael we're good man how
are you not too bad how are you doing Oh
Jay Jay rise right ah there we go all
right all right all right how are we
doing today great you have a question
yeah I have some cry have a couple
questions man I'm ready I'm ready to
launch man oh yeah I'm ready to launch
and I and I need to know who I go to
that's what I'm doing what do we launch
it I am ready to launch a good I have a
I have a book okay a little poem book
that i have already wrote called our man
good stuff okay and I have another one
that is backing it and it is gonna be
cut off you got cut off I think it's in
two min Stein it sounded good here's a
pawn okay well let's give from God even
though he's out here let's get some
value right so he's watching a poem book
is backed by another phone book right so
high as he launches Palma as a gator got
there you give away teasers right
demonstrate you want to show people to
value for your work you can give away a
teaser with a good clear corner action
at the end you know who enjoyed this
poem go here to purchase um simple clean
clear you can do what you're doing with
your book build up an audience uh you
know campaign launch new book see a
video series on you first time to waste
won't you yeah so I mean I'm going to
this right now because I'm building I'm
creating my book that should be out in
December January will see a couple
couple ideas one you want to connect
with influencers right so what's the
book about what kind of poems are you
writing about and then connect with
people who have that audience like if
they're entrepreneur poems and connect
with me and maybe I'll share one both of
like the subject matter so
there are people who love poems and so
you can give them the poem book and
there be something that they can
potentially review and then whoever the
kind of general audience would be is it
lifestyle is it you know entrepreneurs
is it for you know people have pets is
it like whatever like what was the
audience and in five influencers in no
space to connect with and if you send a
sample you know one one poem is an
example it should be something that
moves them right like if you sent me an
awesome entrepreneur poem I should be
moved by it right and then you send them
copies and hit review it hopefully in
similitude honestly give you some
exposure um the second thing I've been
doing is creating content create
consistent content talking about what
either you're doing like reading trivia
palms or whatever the message is we're
going to run again right like hold on
everything we're doing now right is this
guy go to youtube this all helps me
build my platform for then when my book
comes out it has a greater reach so you
guys need to be creating consistent
content whether it's the songs I know
you've written some songs and play on
your channel you know doing reading from
the book or just sharing whatever your
mantra is or your thought of the day
doing collaborations with other artists
interview with your clothes yeah just
Billy consistent content that is good
stuff right like zero in the comment
says he better have some good stuff to
share buddy agree you're sharing good
stuff right that's in your name and
people are going to follow you pay
attention and be interested in what you
have to offer right you don't just go up
somebody's ahead buy my book but if
they're following you they like your
video they like your newsletter you're
like some of the samples right the more
they get to know you like your trust you
because of the consistent content you
point out then the more likely you don't
want to buy the book so those two things
corporations and influencers and then
create your own consistent content to
generate attention let's question ND
here have you been in environments that
became politically charged to the point
where affected operations also have you
ever had relationships as for my
business if so how do you deal with it
yes this is a jerez has some interesting
different perspectives on these things
so that I'm curious
be exciting yeah well uh yeah so I've
been in all these situations uh I have
pretty unique views on a lot of things
and those news I stand by them I stand
for them I believe them with all my
heart and I think a lot of pride in
making sure that I'm spot on with them
and so a lot of times i get i get a
clash with my environment or the people
i'm around so i walked out you know with
quick jabs i fired people let people go
i like stop talking to my family
brothers sisters aunts uncles because to
me ah if you're on earth to fulfill a
mission at the dream if you have an idea
if you're going to be an entrepreneur
and you believe in something you have to
stand by it no matter what is happening
and I mean it can get pretty awkward and
pretty messy and it might not be like I
don't I don't wish it on anyone but I
did it and I wouldn't take it back like
I do it again and I'll feel like no
matter what's going on around you or in
your life like the most important thing
is that you have integrity with yourself
and authenticity with yourself and you
stand up for what you believe in so like
it um centricity environment you know if
you guys have watched any of the videos
on my channel recently I go on and on
about the importance of a good
environment um it's in a good book to
this true you plug in the book see were
creating content amazing book really is
um you know I try to I try to design an
environment that supports me to be the
best burger than myself and create
greatness that inspires me to be great
and do something beyond stretch myself
every day I create that environment with
intent every day and so part of creating
great environment is not being a crappy
one right so I don't know what your
environment is right now if you have a
job when you're working at a bad company
as a you know you're a bad boss you know
for me I would be looking at moving on
looking at even if I'm just being an
employee maybe you're not ready to take
the leap into entrepreneurship but find
in a place that you don't want to go
somewhere on a regular basis that sucks
that drains your energy right you want
to go somewhere that makes you a better
version of yourself you're learning
something you're growing you're
contributing somehow and so if that was
an environment that I was going to a
daily basis and have to change it and
you you have the control the changing
the government employee can't change it
go find a different job change it this
tons of jobs as here's an example just
to change your environment I took over
Toronto dance salsa in I had fluorescent
lights fluorescent lights kill me like I
can't handle it it you know the
flickering gives me headaches and so the
first thing I did was I changed out all
the links because I wanted to create a
better environment for myself as well as
for the students now we're doing a bunch
of things in there are one word is
family so we have a family tree plastic
people yeah it's a bunch of things that
I want people to have an emotional
reaction coming by my storefront right I
want them to feel something coming by so
i want to feel something and I want them
to feel something and so you want to
create an environment that build that up
for yourself and if you are an employee
again you can go on point on the job but
also think about think about your room
like think about what you wake up in
right this is our stuff on the walls
that inspires you or is it just a boring
room thinking about your community are
you are you taking the subway or you
driving is there anything in your car
now makes you come alive when you
listening to audiobooks or is there
something on the steering wheel or like
everything matters and bring every 10
minutes up in your life matters and you
want to have it as something that builds
you up so you think of great things and
then that lets you go off on deep
tangents we went off on a great one
today we're just brainstorming because
in the grammys I really had and then
like I shut down for an hour just go
intense and creation mode and will
praise something that this condition is
pretty amazing really shines in history
yeah so you know that came because we
created the environment for that right
you can't come up with great ideas if
you're in a crappy environment and so
look at everything that surrounded to
reason why this is on
all this when I logo is an airplane you
know other stuff in here is a reason why
it exists in as much as possible you
want to create a positive environment
for yourself and bring it back to people
because of his question with all my
creation ships and politics and
beautiful it's all changing your
environment to meet the most important
change you can make is the people what
we do great things here but if I thought
there was a person around that was not
like I couldn't vibe with or it was a
negative energy or it draining me I'd
begun I've begun the heartbeat because
people are the one of the most important
parts of the environment you can
decorate everything all you want with
this video's firing orders you want but
the people on your team and your staff
at your life your family your friends
super important you scenics in school so
that's for the scheduling sure yeah so I
mean but you change schools yeah and you
know and there's a lot of time you're
not in school right and you can find
that and you need to make sure you're
carving out time for your business I'm
not just really if you say I'm going to
do this after school right then they go
they after school's done you can get a
job go I'm going to do this like you
keep the firm in it I drop down keep the
fur in your life and then you ever get
anything done and you look back and say
we're at the time ago right so you know
you have more time now that you're in
school Dan you will when you have a job
so that's the time they want to do it in
terms of as a business that were
impacted my relationship I've hired I'm
like the first guy that I hired I know
almost full-time basis was my best
friend is a four scalar high five to you
for the frogs make sure the props who is
that I don't want a problem cover over
will cover it I can't see Jonathan thank
jonathan thank you both for the props
lots of props um yeah angel was his name
and he's still a friend and I think the
key is just honest communication you
know like the challenge in that sort of
the case I maybe there's some context
for you is he was a writer and I need a
content for my web site and he'd love to
write but he took like every word for
him had to be perfect and when he wrote
I need a content like I needed it I need
a good content but not like two weeks to
read one article content right
made it a little bit faster than just
our timelines weren't working and
instead of yelling at each other and
freaking out on each other we just sat
down inside you know what this is
probably not it's not worth it like
you're not happy i'm not happy I want to
still be friends let's move it on there
so never had I've never had a business
and have hired my sister and I've had
tons of friends I gained friends through
hiring people but I've never had a
relationship destroyed because of
business I think it's just how you
approach it can I give you drugs there's
a guy who was a friend were hired and
then we let go and we just went to his
Facebook page and his profile picture
saying thank you to my mentor Evan
Carmichael from what you are so lame so
whatever like you know I think it's just
a matter of trying not to say things
that you regret I don't like heat of the
moment passion excitement and just open
communication because you're going to
likely you know if they think about it
too it's probably not going to be a fit
for them if they're not happy either so
you guys have to work on your thinking
you just talk about it and so yelling
and doing things your hand each other's
backs you must feel like you to do have
the result you have really good question
yeah jitter eyes an e believe I me
believe now telling nothing but the
truth your environment is so important
cool well hola we gotta head out thank
you guys for the awesome fun I will
probably post it to YouTube we're going
to do bleeders the other hand you
anything right hand your match the point
here believe and we'll see you soon
really appreciate it thank you guys see
you soon